and if the world's best players took
center stage for a shot at the richest
prize fund in online chess history day
one of the quarterfinals and clucks
chess champions showdown Wesley so
grabbed an early lead against Maxine by
Sheila Grove while the young Geoffrey
Jean staged the miniature comeback
against world champion Magnus Carlsen to
keep the match closed with all to play
for in the final day and now we have the
world champion of Magnus Carlsen Magnus
we've got to get your thoughts on how
this match went it seems like the tale
of two halves the first game was obvious
a blender blender 2-piece then games two
and three were pretty good in them and
when it went downhill tomorrow while
Levon Aronian beat Alexander Grichuk in
the day's final game to take a slim lead
in their match Fabiano Khurana bounced
back from an early loss against the NIR
Dominguez to win three in a row while
Magnus Carlsen took a big hit from the
youngster Geoffrey Zhang but bounced
back to dominate the finish and move on
to the semi-finals Wesley so continued
his fantastic play to cruise past Maxime
Vash Selig Rob while Levon Aronian and
Alexander Griz Chuck fought like
gladiators with the Armenian superstar
rising to the occasion in the final game
I'm loving this fields we have right now
who are the best of the best that we've
got on the planet let's take a look at
the brackets as we have world champion
Magnus Carlsen playing in falaqa von
aronia and then we have Wensley so
against Aviano Arowana danger to anyone
world champion Magnus Carlsen ran up a
dominant six to score against Levon
Aronian while Wesley so did the same
against Viviano Caruana
to take a commanding lead going into the
second half will the frontrunners close
things out or is there an epic comeback
in the making it was door die time in
the semi-finals of Clark's chess
champion showdown world champion Magnus
Carlsen sealed the deal against Levon
Aronian while Fabiano Caruana staged an
epic comeback against Wesley so to book
his ticket to the championship round
we have our first finalist Viviano
Khurana congratulations what an epic
comeback
I bet that you wouldn't win this one how
did you get the confidence to pull this
off and for me I mean it doesn't matter
if I you know lose by one point or lose
by eight points I mean I had one thought
today which is that I really have
nothing to lose
it's Magnus versus Fabi number one
versus number two world champion Magnus
Carlsen played masterfully to take the
lead twice but Fabiano Caruana bounced
back each time to tie up the match going
into the final day hello everyone and
welcome to the final day in the final
match of this clutch chassis bent I tell
you it's been a script writers dream
number one and number two players
trading heavy blows with one another
he's winning he's completely winning and
he's designed yeah Magnus has resigned
Magnus now has to win the final game in
order to become the clutch just yeah
bien Wow
that's it it's over Magnus Carlsen is
victorious the sure sign came up right
there but Magnus comes in in the end you
got to give it to Magnus he's a clutch
player